[Music]
from the book of saw
[Music]
get your [ __ ] hands in the air
i ain't gonna say it again [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
hello detective boswick i want to play a
game
the three train is arriving in two
minutes it is up to you to decide if
this will be your final stop
you have taken the witness stand many
times and reloaded innocent people with
your lies putting them away in jail
today it is you who will be railroaded
you have one chance to live tear from
your mouth the tongue that has so often
been used to light and to deceive
take a leap of faith and you will live
only your weight
will rip away your mind tongue and save
you live or die
make your choice
[Applause]
um
ugh
[Music]
12 years ago i turned in a dirty cop
i get a medal for it big deal i also got
a
bullet and i got to look over my back
for the rest of my career
shut up it's too hot here for me to
listen to this
i got a heat wave going on we got
rolling blackouts the city is nuts
stop you wanna see me captain yeah come
in
zeke i want you to meet detective in
training william shank
he was the top of his academy so don't
screw this up
zeke is going to break you in show you
the ropes stuck to banks
yup go yeah
thanks in route to that 1019 would that
be north or south side of the street
copy that what are you doing
oh it's just uh family this is my wife
emma's is my son charlie
cute we just met but you're you know
you're firing already i appreciate it
all i'm saying is you know most crime
happens on
weekends holidays so you would think
anybody married to a cop would
understand this
no one day your wife will be angry
because you couldn't go to her sister's
birthday dinner
you can give a woman 600 tuesdays it
ain't worth three saturday nights
what is that
play me
okay whoa we done
don't want to [ __ ] up my computer
hello detective banks i'm here to help
reform the metro police
to remind them of their oath to the
people of this city
one officer from your station refused to
be reformed
he will not be the last to play my game
that spiral is what i think it is jinxer
wait i thought the jigsaw killer was
dead yeah but if it's another copycat
it's gonna be a [ __ ] show
you pull a gun on your old man you out
here [ __ ] your mind
i could have killed you what are you
talking about i got the gun i could have
killed you
how did you get in here you forget who
the landlord is yeah but that doesn't
give you the right to just walk in here
anytime you want
renter's got rights you start paying
some rent you can get some rights
i heard about buzz you all right
nah dad i'm i'm [ __ ] up
sorry hit it i know how close you were
jigsaw copycat
that could be difficult
[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here
play me
[Music]
hello detective banks do you know where
your officers are
jigsaw i thought the jigsaw killer was
dead
he is
find him their hours not days how can i
catch this guy
if there's nobody on the bus i can fuss
you can't do this alone whoever did this
has another motive
something personal was the last time you
saw your father
[Music]
down that was just a diversion to get us
out of the precinct
i need everyone on this case
it could be anywhere he could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Music]
hello detective banks when was the last
time
you saw your father
[Music]
you